find the probability of pulling a yellow
marble from a bag with three yellow to
red to green and one blue marbles I'm
assuming so let's just think about this
bag a little bit there are three yellow
marbles in it so let me draw them we
have 1 2 3 yellow marbles we have 2 red
marbles 2 red marbles so we have 1 2 red
marbles assuming they're all mixed in
there we have 2 green marbles 1 2 green
marbles and then there's one blue marble
and there's one blue marble and they
want to know the probability of pulling
a yellow marble so they want to know
they want to know what is the
probability of probability of pulling a
yellow yellow marble of a yellow marble
now probability is just a way of
expressing the well I don't want to use
two loaded words but it's the odds of
picking yours relative to the odds of
picking everything else or another way
of thinking about it is it's the number
of outcomes that could result in what
you want yellow marble over the number
of total number of outcomes so how many
ways are there to how many events you're
gonna pick out a ball how many of those
how many ways or how many balls can you
pick out that will be yellow well
there's three balls there's three balls
that you can pick out of yellow 1 2 and
3 we're assuming that they're all
equally likely to be picked up they're
all mixed in there so there's three
yellow balls you could pick up now how
many total balls are there how many
total balls are there to be picked up
well you could be picking up any one of
eight balls right 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 so
there's a total number of 8 balls so the
probability of picking a yellow marble
is 3/8 then you have a 3/8 chance of
picking a ye of a yellow marble and just
the way to think about I just want to
reiterate it's just the number of
outcomes the number of of there's 8
total outcomes there's 8 different
things that you could pull out of the
bag 3 of them satisfy your conditions
3 of them would be a yellow would be a
yellow marble